Welcome, students, to
Pharmacokinetics Part 2,
Principles of Metabolism
and Excretion.
And we will also talk
about the individual
variation in
response to drugs. We
talk about the big
picture, and then
we'll drill down to
what happens that can
cause changes in
our expectation to
drug response in the
individual patient.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
please contact me if
you'd like to have a
chat about pharmacology
individuals and
groups are welcome
here are the learning
objectives mechanisms
mechanisms mechanisms
and these is all
about bio elimination
elimination by
biotransformation in other words
metabolism and
elimination by excretion.
My suggestions,
and please do
the practice
questions, they
will help you.
Here are some links
you might find
helpful if you
wish to use them.
I talked about the
key elements of
metabolism and
excretion in In
part one, this is
what we'll cover.
And let us begin
with the general
principles of
drug metabolism.
These are enzyme
-catalyzed conversion
of our drug, a
chemical, to some other
molecule, some other
chemical. We have
many, many protein
drugs that have been
developed in the
past 20 or 25 years.
Protein drugs are
subject to metabolism as
other proteins are,
proteolytic cleavage.
We need to also be
thinking about the
individual patient in
terms of pharmacogenomics.
People do have
variabilities in the
expression of their
various metabolic enzymes.
We'll talk about phase
1 and phase 2 reactions.
The genetic factors,
as I said, and we'll
also talk about
inhibition and induction,
which are mechanisms
of drug interactions.
Super important
concept. We'll go
into that more in
later lectures.
the liver is the
principal organ of drug
metabolism drug
metabolism concurrent can
occur in many tissues
but the liver is
actually built to do
that it has a large
blood flow it has a portal
circulation directly
from the intestines
to the liver it
has open spaces
sinusoidal fenestrations,
they're called, allowing
the blood to bring
all sorts of substances
into the liver,
high concentration
of metabolic enzymes,
of transporters,
both the solute
carrier type and the
primary active that
use ATP for energy.
Solute carriers
are located in the
basolateral membrane
where they can allow
substrates to go
into the hepatocytes.
and ABC transporters,
our ATP type, are
located in the bile
canalicular system
in order to expulse
or efflux drugs
into the biliary
system for excretion.
This is just a quick
scheme. I will keep
talking about the
portal system.
Looking on the left
-hand side, the spleen,
stomach, pancreas,
small intestine,
colon, the whole
intestine drains into the
portal vein, which
goes to the liver.
The liver then goes
via the vena cava into
the heart, the right
atrium, and gets
cycled through the
heart, and the left
ventricle pushes blood
into the aorta, which
then leads to delivering
blood through the
arterial system to
all parts of the body.
This figure
shows the liver
and the gallbladder
underneath.
gallbladder squeezes
out the bile acids
when a person eats a
fatty meal bile acids
go into the duodenum
to emulsify that
fat for digestion and
it travels through
this is representing
the entire small
intestine to the
terminal ileum where the
bile acids the large
majority of bile acids
are then reabsorbed
back into the portal
vein, back into the
liver, where they
get recycled back
into the gallbladder.
Very efficient system.
If a drug enters the
gallbladder through
the bile canalicular
system, that
also will go back
into the intestine.
and if it's a certain
metabolic product
like a glucuronide
then that may
actually be reactivated
which I'll go into
back into the portal
vein but otherwise
it just gets
excreted in the feces
and this is a picture
an illustration of
the liver lobule to
kind of give you the
landmarks to to be able
to visualize what's
going on in the liver
that you don't have to
memorize that I just
wanted to explain the
portal system and how
important that is when
we're talking about
drugs especially oral
drugs drugs may be
biotransformed to inactive
active or toxic
metabolites or more
hydrophilic readily
excretable products drugs
can also pass through
the liver unchanged
what happens is for
effective drugs that
pass through the liver
a certain fraction
of them will be
secreted unchanged
into the systemic
circulation and therefore
be available to
produce their effect.
Drug enters hepatocyte
through transporter,
solute carrier
transporter.
Drug has a number
of different
metabolic pathways
it can go into.
Phase one to a metabolite,
that metabolite
may be secreted into
the bile canaliculus
or it may just be
forming a metabolite
or two metabolites
or a variety of
metabolites and be secreted
into the bloodstream,
into the systemic
circulation. These
are most frequently
inactive, so they
would be excreted,
usually in the kidney.
These are excreted in
the feces, anything
that goes through
the bile canaliculi.
The drug may also go
straight to phase 2
and be secreted as
a metabolite, an
inactive metabolite
usually, vastly more
frequently as an an
active metabolite than
something that has
some sort of activity.
Or that metabolite
may be secreted into
the bile canaliculus.
And this is most
frequently the glucuronide
metabolite that
gets secreted into
the bile canaliculi.
Not exclusively,
but most frequently.
The drug can
be excreted as
is into the
bile canaliculi.
The drug can be excreted
as is into the
bloodstream.
So we have all of these
different options.
The vast majority of
drugs, though, will
undergo some level
of metabolism in the
liver. And if these
are oral drugs, they
will undergo on the
first pass through.
So let's talk about
first pass metabolism.
This is also called
first pass effect.
Drug gets swallowed,
goes to stomach,
goes to small
intestine where it is
absorbed. and it
enters the portal
circulation ah but there
are metabolic enzymes
in the epithelial
cells of the gut
and the drug may be
metabolized also in
the gut not all
drugs but some drugs
the drug gets to the
liver and it undergoes
metabolism to some
degree which i will
talk about more in
a future lecture so
because this is oral
administration and
goes to the liver
first it's called first
pass effect or first
pass metabolism or
first pass hepatic
metabolism all of those
are the same meaning,
the same process.
Any drug that actually
leaves the liver as
active drug into the
systemic circulation will
then produce its
effect and the fraction
that enters the systemic
circulation is called
the bioavailability
of the drug it is
available biologically
to produce its biological
effect so first pass
metabolism first pass
effect so let's talk
about phase one metabolic
reactions these are
oxidation reduction
and hydrolysis what happens
here is a functional
group is exposed
something like this
these are pretty typical
and that will most
frequently it caused
inactivation of the drug
molecule which may then
be secreted and into
the systemic circulation
and excreted or
secreted into the biliary
system and excreted.
Sometimes an active
metabolite is formed.
That active metabolite
goes into the systemic
circulation and
produces an effect and
is eventually
inactivated through
other metabolic
processes.
Toxic metabolites
can form.
Sometimes the product
will undergo phase two
because it's not
soluble enough to be
excreted as a hydrophilic
compound in the kidney.
So we have all these
different options.
The cytochrome P450
mixed function oxidase
system are really
the most frequent
phase one metabolic
reactions. It's
this big super family
it's called and
they're referred to as
CYPs. I refer to them
as CYPs. Many people
call them CYPs.
They are abundant in
the liver. They're
present in many other
tissues. They are located
on the lipophilic
membranes of the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum.
So they're kind of
hanging out right
there on the membranes.
And when a substrate
passes by and binds to
it, it will then
metabolize that molecule.
They have low
substrate specificity.
That means that
they're capable
of metabolizing
many, many, many,
many different
types of substrates.
And that's not all they
do, not just drugs.
They're also involved
in the metabolism
of steroids and fatty
acids and many other
products in our body,
natural products.
Heme is required.
Heme has iron in
it, and iron is
essential for the
action of the CYPs.
I'll explain that
on the next slide.
They are susceptible
to inhibition and
induction. In
other words, if a
substrate is present
on the active site of
the CYP and another
drug comes along,
the second drug
will not be able
to access the
active site and will
therefore pass
by unmetabolized.
When there is significant
inhibition of CYPs,
there can be an increase
in the bioavailability,
an increase in the
amount of drug that
actually reaches the
systemic circulation.
So there is a higher
concentration of drug in
the systemic circulation.
And remember, the
amount of drug in the
systemic circulation
determines the amount
of drug at the site of
action, which in turn
determines the magnitude
of the effect. So
this is a drug interaction
that could lead to
increased effect
toxicity adverse effects.
Induction, on the other
hand, is an increase
in the number of
enzymes available. As
a result, the rate
of drug metabolism
increases, which can
lower the amount of drug
that reaches the
systemic circulation.
And we also have
pharmacogenetic
mutations in drug
metabolism. That's
really what this
is all about.
Where the enzyme
is changed somehow
compared to the
majority of the
population. Perhaps it
is under-functioning.
Perhaps it is
over-functioning.
The mechanism of
CYPs, as I said,
they're embedded
in the membrane
of the endoplasmic
reticulum.
And here's a blow up
of that they have this
heme inside and it
is the heme that's
essential for this
oxidative reaction here's
our substrate it's
going to bump into our
drug metabolizing enzyme
and be metabolized
and here's the process
a A reducing agent
is required, and here
we have our reductase.
We also need oxygen,
and of course the drug.
So the drug plus
the reducing agent
will, well, let
me start here.
Here's drug.
Step number one. It goes
through the process,
picks up an electron,
picks up oxygen,
and becomes oxidized.
you do not have to
memorize this whole cycle
this is the part you
need to remember the
drug the oxygen the
reducing agent produces
the metabolite let's
check your knowledge
i invite you to pause
the video see if
you can answer these
questions without
looking them up and
then go ahead and look
them up and try and
answer them again
okay let's look at the
answer CYP metabolism
requires what three
elements heme the
reducing agent NADPH and
oxygen CYP 450 enzymes
are called mono
oxygenases adds an oxygen
CYPs are susceptible
to alteration in
rates of drug
elimination, rates, rates,
everything in pharmacokinetics
is about rates,
by what?
Inhibition or
induction of CYPs
and by pharmacogenetic or
pharmacogenomics
variabilities.
How do these alterations
potentially affect
patient care?
Alterations in plasma
drug concentrations
can lead to increased
potential for
toxicity by inhibition
or an under-functioning
enzyme, or reduced
efficacy by induction
or an ultra-rapidly
functioning enzyme.
How is a knowledge of
clinically relevant
pharmacokinetic
properties of drugs
essential for
patient care. This is
why we're learning
about all of this.
Mechanisms of drug
interactions and effects
of organ function on
plasma drug levels.
Because it is
the drug levels
that determine the
levels at the site of
action that determines
the magnitude of effect.
Efficacy and the
potential for adverse
effects. The right
drug and the right dose
for the right duration
for optimal outcomes.
Please make this part
of your second nature.
all right phase two
metabolic reactions
now these transfer
hydrophilic group
to the substrate
increasing its polarity
and the products
are really almost
always 99.9 percent
of the time inactive.
These are conjugation
reactions. They
transfer a molecule, a
hydrophilic molecule,
from a cofactor and
place it on the drug
or metabolite. So
they're transferring.
The enzymes, therefore,
are transferases.
This example is UDP
-glucuronaciltransferase
or glucuronal
transferase. Both
terms are correct.
Which is the major
transferase in the Phase
II armamentarium of
metabolic reactions.
UGT1A1 is a
pretty common one.
This is how
they are called.
UDP,
glucuronaciltransferase,
UGT for short.
And that's all there
is to it. It takes
molecule from a
donor and attaches
it to the drug
molecule or metabolite.
That's it.
Hydrophilic, excretion,
usually through
the kidney.
These are the six
different transferases.
So UGT I mentioned
was the major one.
It gets its glucuronic
acid from UDP,
uridine diphosphate,
glucuronic acid.
You do not need
to memorize
the names of
the cofactors.
get the idea that they
are bringing along
the hydrophilic molecule
to be transferred
to the drug or
metabolite. You do
need to know the name
of the transferases.
So we have UGT,
UDP-glucuronacil
transferase, or glucuronal
transferase, both
are correct. A
sulfotransferase, transferring
a sulfate. You
do need to know
what gets transferred,
not the cofactor.
And acetyltransferase,
we will be
talking about
this plenty of
times because of
pharmacogenetics.
So acetyl, naturally.
Methyltransferase,
transfers methyl.
Glutathione.
super important in
our bodies because
this catalyzes the
nucleophilic attack of
glutathione on
electrophilic atoms and
xenobiotics and toxic
metabolites so what's
all of that all of
that that were all
those words what is
the take-home message
it detoxifies reactive
oxygen species.
And when we run
out of glutathione
S transferase
because of starvation
or serious, serious
illness, then
these toxic metabolites
can hurt us.
Glycine is a
little amino acid.
It's seen
occasionally. It's not
really one of the
major pathways.
Anyway, these are
all hydrophilic
metabolites that
result and they
can be readily
excreted in urine.
Now let's talk about
enterohepatic circulation
and we'll talk about
them as glucuronide
metabolites which is
the vast majority.
Here on the left
is a picture of the
arrangement of the
organs and the liver.
Stomach, so food
goes in here.
Small intestine,
large intestine.
Here is the portal
circulation draining
all of these organs
and the veins,
the venous circulation
in the liver.
Okay, so that's how
it's set up. So what
we're going to be talking
about with enteroepatic
circulation is as
the drug travels from
the gallbladder, which
is in here underneath
the liver, into the
duodenum and travels
through the small
intestine, and it gets down
here, it will then be
reabsorbed into the
portal circulation and
go back to the liver.
okay so what's
happening drug
gets swallowed drug gets
absorbed from the
small intestine
goes to the liver
via the portal system
gets a glucuronide stuck
on it that glucuronide
metabolite goes into
the biliary system
and gets stored in
the gallbladder along
with bile acids
Now, somebody eats a
fatty meal, and the
glucuronide metabolite is
excreted along with
the bile acids and
transported in this
really very simple figure
here, down here to
the terminal ileum.
So that glucuronide
group is cleaved
off by intestinal
bacteria
flora, which are
populating this area
and the whole
large intestine.
When that glucuronide
gets cleaved off, we
now have active
drug again, and it's
lipophilic. So by passive
diffusion, it goes back
into the portal
system and back to the
liver where it may
be undergo this same
situation again. But we
need to remember it's
not 100% of the drug
that gets metabolized.
I don't know what
percentage it
is, so I'll make
up a percentage.
Let's say 50% of the
original drug got
metabolized and goes
into the gallbladder
and blah, blah,
blah and around the
circle. So, now, what's
coming back in will
get metabolized about
50% of that, and
all of this goes
into the bloodstream.
The other 50%
goes into the
bloodstream as
active drug.
Therefore, with
enterohepatic
circulation, that
can contribute to the
levels in the
systemic circulation.
So that's the
takeaway message with
enterohepatic
circulation of drugs.
well i keep talking
about all these various
enzymes so what
role do they play in
metabolism each individual
one on this figure we
see the cyp3a4 and 5s
the cyp3a family is
about 50% of the CYP
oxidative metabolism.
Different sources have
different fractions,
but the point is they
all agree that the
majority of CYP activity
is by CYP3A family.
CYP2D6 plays a pretty
decent portion.
We'll talk about that
with pharmacogenomics
at a later
time, and we see
little slices from
all these others.
UGT here also
is the majority
of the transferase
activity.
Sulfates has a
pretty good size,
glutathione,
N-acetyltransferase,
and all the rest.
You don't have to
memorize this, just take
away the points that
CYP3A family and UDP
glucuronal transferase
are very, very
important pathways. But
so are the others, they
just don't handle
quite as much traffic.
All right, check
your knowledge.
I, again, invite you
to pause the computer,
take a look at
these questions, see
if you can answer
them without looking.
Okay, let us return now.
How do phase 2 reactions
differ from phase
1 reactions?
Think of three ways.
Phase I reactions
are oxidation.
Phase II are conjugation.
Phase I expose a
functional group.
Phase II transfer
a hydrophilic
substance from
a cofactor.
Phase I
metabolites may be
inactive, active, toxic.
Phase II metabolites
are hydrophilic,
readily excreted, and
almost always inactive.
True or false?
Phase II reactions
must follow Phase
I reactions.
No, that's
false, of course.
Drugs that have a
polar functional group
already exposed on their
structures may directly
undergo a Phase II
conjugation reaction.
What types of drug
metabolites frequently
undergo enteropatic
circulation? The
glucuronide metabolites,
which may go
through the kidney, or
they may be secreted
into the biliary
system by P
-glycoprotein efflux or
by passive diffusion.
These are two
methods by which
drugs get into the
biliary system.
Bacteria that express
beta-glucuronidase
cleave the
glucuronide, releasing
free drug, which is
then reabsorbed by
passive diffusion in
the terminal ileum.
Excretion now.
The kidney is by far
the most frequent
route of excretion
of drugs and
metabolites and lots
of other things.
They eliminate
polar compounds
more efficiently
than substances
with high lipid
solubility.
Renal drug handling.
They may be filtered
from the blood in the
glomerulus. So let's
say this is the
glomerulus. This is drug
going in through the
afferent arteriole.
The blood goes through
the capillary system
in the glomerulus and
goes out through the
efferent arteriole.
And meanwhile, the
plasma gets filtered by
this capillary system
that has fenestrations
or spaces in between
the capillaries, and
the drug or metabolites
go into the nephron.
Another way to get
them in, because
plasma, only about
20% of plasma
gets filtered at
any pass through.
There is a tubular
capillary network that
goes around the nephron.
Don't go by this
picture, it doesn't
really show you, because
it's intended to show
you something else.
Drug in the
bloodstream can also be
secreted into the
nephron. So those
are two pathways
to get in there,
glomerular filtration,
active tubular secretion.
Remember, drugs that
are bound to proteins
are not going to
be able to pass
through the glomerulus,
only free drug.
Okay,
now, drug passes
through the nephron,
various things happen
in the nephron, you'll
learn about that in
the renal system. And
it can get into the
distal tubule where it
can be, if it is
lipophilic and active
drug, it can be
reabsorbed back into the
bloodstream and travel
around the body again.
If not, it will be
excreted in the urine.
That's the basic idea.
glomerular filtration
or active tubular
secretion to get
into the nephron,
passive reabsorption
out of the distal
tubule if it is
lipophilic, and
otherwise it gets
excreted in the urine.
Altering the urinary
pH to favor ionization
can enhance excretion
of charged species,
charged forms of weak
acids or weak bases.
renal function is not
constant even in the
healthy person the
neonate's renal function
is low compared with
body mass but matures
rapidly within the first
few months of birth
adults experience a
slow decline in renal
function inexorable
elderly patients may
have substantial kidney
function impairment,
even if it's not
caused by disease.
And of course,
both acute and
chronic disease can
certainly modify
renal function.
Here's a better picture
of the glomerulus
and the capillary
network inside here.
There are big
spaces, it's kind of
indicated by these
little dots here.
Those are big spaces
where plasma gets
filtered through
into the nephron.
Filtered because it
takes in the plasma and
solutes anything
that's dissolved in
the plasma, but keeps
out the proteins.
Oops, excuse me,
wrong button.
The takeaway here,
this is what you are
expected to remember.
the glomerular filtration
rate is a determinant
of renal function we
will be talking about
renal function when it
comes to drug therapy
over and over and over
and what we're talking
about is the ability
of the glomerulus to
do its filtration job
glomerular
filtration rate is a
useful measure of
renal function there
are limitations
it is a biomarker.
Glomerular filtration
rate is the
sum of all of the
functioning nephrons
and it is a
rough measure of
the number of
functioning nephrons.
The rate of filtration.
Serum creatinine
and creatinine
clearance are
estimates, biomarkers
of glomerular
filtration rate.
Creatinine is the end
product of creatine
metabolism from
skeletal muscle.
Please don't confuse
these two terms.
Creatinine
production is stable.
Creatinine is filtered
through the glomerulus
and a small amount
is secreted and
it's not reabsorbed.
So that's why measuring
creatinine in the
blood or creatinine
in the urine is an
estimate of glomerular
filtration rate. The
rate at which creatinine
passes through is
essentially equal
to GFR. And I'm saying
essentially there
are drawbacks, but
that's a lecture for a
later time. Nonetheless,
it's still a
frequently used indicator
of renal function,
and we use it for
renal dosing, dosing
for individuals who
have renal impairment.
I'm not going to ask
you to memorize these
various equations
and there are a
number of automatic
equations that you can
get where you just
put in the numbers and
the computer will
work it out for you.
Creatinine clearance
is determined by
collecting a timed
urine sample. 24 hours
sample is the
standard of care and
clearance is then
expressed in milliliters
per minute. That's
how we talk about GFR
and milliliters per
minute of clearance.
So let's check the
knowledge again. I invite
you to pause the video
and see if you can
come up with these
answers from your memory.
Okay so let us return.
What are the processes
involved in renal
excretion of drugs
and metabolites?
Molecules not bound to
plasma proteins enter
the kidney via
glomerular filtration or
act of secretion into
the proximal tubule.
If lipophilic, they
may be passively
reabsorbed in the distal
tubule. If not, drugs
and metabolites are
excreted in the urine.
What is the most
frequently used biomarker
of kidney function serum
creatinine also urine
creatinine which requires
a urine collection
over time serum
creatinine is a blood
test glomerular filtration
rate shows how well
the kidneys are filtering
and finally what
is the clinical
relevance of gfr on drug
therapy A low GFR means
kidney function is
impaired, which means
drugs may not be excreted
at the usual rate
and can accumulate in
the blood, increasing
the risk of toxicity.
This is why we care.
Drug therapy may
need to be adjusted,
and we call this
renal dosing.
And finally, variation
in drug response.
Many, many factors
can impact the rate at
which drugs are cleared,
are eliminated, and
these need to be taken
into consideration
when considering
drug therapy for your
individual patient,
whether it's for adjustment
of dosing or possibly
avoiding certain
drugs. This wheel lists
all of these different
things that it could
be and I'd like to
also add to it genetic
variability. Don't
forget about that. This
is becoming much easier
to identify as screening
tests are becoming
more available and
more affordable the
older patient and the
neonates i'll focus
on them for the older
patient there may
be multiple concurrent
diseases that are
going to affect
your drug therapy so
drug disease
interactions intestinal
intestinal motility may
be reduced blood flow
may be reduced muscle
mass may reduced
body fat may be
increased kidney function
reduction liver
function reduction and
then just general
structural and functional
changes in the brain
that can occur.
In the neonate, they
have immature processes,
absorption, distribution,
metabolism,
and excretion.
We have to be
very, very careful
dosing them,
and it should
be left to the
neonatologist.
Blood flow, GI function,
they are just little
bags of water,
especially the
********* babies.
lower plasma protein
binding capacity
because their livers
are not producing them
to the same degree
as in the older
child even the older
infant low activity
of the drug
metabolizing enzymes and
transporters they're
not mature yet lower
glomerular filtration
rate potentially or
even higher glomerular
filtration rate.
So in summary, I have
put you a little mind
map again. If you find
these helpful, make
them yourself. You
can make simple ones.
They don't have to be
complicated and they
can help you connect
the dots as it were.
Here's another one.
And biotransformation
is a complex
process involving
numerous enzyme systems
that usually detoxify
the xenobiotics.
Xeno meaning
foreign or not
occurring naturally
in our bodies.
Phase I reactions include
oxidation, reduction,
hydrolysis. These
processes unmask a
polar functional group.
And the products may
be inactive, usually,
or active or toxic.
Phase II reactions
involve the addition
of a subgroup, and
that's called a
conjugation, with the
drug or metabolite.
These are the
glucuronide, I should
say glucuronide,
not glucuronate,
acetate, sulfate,
methylate,
and glycine groups.
The enzymes that
catalyze the
reactions are
called transferases.
they transfer the
subgroup supplied
by a cofactor
onto the substrate
phase two metabolites
are significantly
more hydrophilic
than the substrate
and are readily
excreted usually
definitely most frequently
in the urine drugs
metabolized by both
phase one and phase
two reactions may undergo
phase 1 before phase
2 or go directly to
phase 2 or there may be
complicated metabolic
reactions occurring.
Drug disposition is also
affected by membrane
transport proteins
which mediate the
cellular uptake and
efflux of xenobiotics in
the liver, kidney, and
many many many other
tissues. The Phase I
CYP enzymes biotransform
most xenobiotics. CYPs
are expressed in a
high concentration in
the membrane of the
smooth endoplasmic
reticulum of the liver and
in lower concentrations
in other tissues.
CYPs are relatively
non-selective. A
small number of P450
isoforms metabolize
thousands and
thousands of drugs.
CYP3A4 is the most
abundant isoform
metabolizing in some
estimates, in most
estimates, about
50% of all drugs.
Enzyme activity can
vary due to concurrent
administration of other
drugs that inhibit
or induce the drug
metabolizing enzymes.
Enzyme inhibition
can reduce the
rate of metabolism
of the substrate
drug, leading to
increased systemic
levels, increased
bioavailability.
Enzyme induction
increases the
rate of metabolism
of the substrates,
reducing bioavailability.
CYP enzyme activity
is quite variable
due to pharmacogenetic
variabilities.
These are genetic
polymorphisms,
in other words,
switches in the
amino acid positions
in the DNA.
So these are genetic
changes that exist
in at least 1% of
the human population.
So this is the study
of pharmacogenomics.
Most drugs are excreted
in urine, either
as the parent compound,
that is to say the
unchanged drug, active
drug, or as metabolites
with polar characteristics.
Minor routes
of excretion include
sweat, saliva, tears,
skin, hair, and
certainly breast milk.
Think baby.
The processes
involved in renal
elimination are
glomerular filtration
and or active
tubular secretion,
passive tubular
reabsorption of
lipophilic drugs,
and then excretion in
urine. Only free
drug molecules, those
that are not bound
to plasma proteins,
are filtered by
the glomerulus.
The concentration of
drug excreted in urine
results from the amount
of drug introduced
to the nephrons through
glomerular filtration
and secretion in
the proximal tubule,
minus the amount
reabsorbed in the distal
tubule, and that gets
excreted, obviously.
Interindividual
variations can affect
the rate and extent
of drug elimination.
Serum creatinine and
creatinine clearance
are biomarkers of
renal function. They
are used to estimate
the glomerular
filtration rate in the
assessment of kidney
function for the
individual patient.
The dose and frequency
of administration
required to achieve
therapeutic blood and
tissue levels vary
in different patients
because of the individual
differences in drug
distribution, rates
of drug metabolism,
and elimination. These
are determined by
genetic factors and non
-genetic variables such
as age, ***, liver
size, liver function,
circadian rhythm,
body temperature,
nutritional,
environmental factors,
concomitant
exposure to inducers
or inhibitors of
drug metabolism.
Here's why we care.
understanding and
employing pharmacokinetic
principles can
increase the probability
of therapeutic
success and reduce the
occurrence of adverse
drug effects in the
body for optimization
of drug therapy
in the individual
patient. Please make
this second nature.
And that concludes
the absorption,
distribution,
metabolism, and excretion
principles of
pharmacokinetics.